the areas that have been talked about
for I landfall here are between Panama
City Beach where we are right now and
also port st. Joe where Omar Villafranca
is Omar what's happening there well
Nicki just mentioned the storm surge we
had a little bit just come off here in
this area as conditions start to
deteriorate here in the port st. Joe
area we've been driving around we've
been seeing these road conditions and
they're not getting any better this is
why they wanted people to evacuate the
area as a matter of fact they issued a
mandatory evacuation for people living
in trailer homes in this area there's
roughly about 3500 people who live in
Port st. Joe and officials believe that
more than half about 60% are still here
and planned to ride it out which makes
things worse there's three bridges
around the port st. Joe area and the
police chief tells us once those bridges
closed
nobody and I mean nobody is gonna be
able to get in or out of the area we met
this Malinsky family in port st. Joe
they have a vacation home there Annalee
is leaving but her husband Jim is gonna
stay behind and ride the storm out
because he's worried about looters what
did you expect I'm just we've got
hurricane windows everything should be
safe hopefully I won't see too much
water coming over but this house has
seen water up to about a foot half a
foot from the bottom or in the carport
area and hopefully I don't see a name
taller than that you have enough
supplies to be there for a few days yes
we do got ice chests full ice and we got
food in the fridge right here if the
utilities go out I'm gonna put the stuff
in the ice chest and we can survive for
a couple days another band is starting
to come through right now and it's got a
lot of wind behind it the National
Hurricane Service is worried that this
particular area is going to be hit by
some serious serious weather we're
talking ten inches of rain
12 foot storm surge 140 mile per hour
winds a matter of fact there's a little
bit of a storm surge that happens to be
coming up behind us right now this is
what they're worried about ambulances
first the hospital shut down at five
o'clock yesterday ambulances all went
north
so if anybody needs any medical
attention right now it's just not gonna
happen Jeff alright Omar thanks very
much I've never seen a hurricane like
this one that has defied expectations in
this way at least covering one up close
we're gonna keep following it down here
for Pento Panama City Beach and Panama